à 15 ans je me suis fait égorger là je
suis passé une cigarette de la mort
bonjour je m'appelle Jo Lopez j'ai écrit
un livre comme vous le voyez et donc je
vais vous raconter ce qui est dans le
film sur ma vie je suis Clermont-Ferrand
d'une famille quand on travaille en
travaillant à l'époque en faisait la
ferraille ferrailleurs
dans un tube non c'est pour dire qu'elle
est dans une cardinale
cheminée là à l'époque mon père il avait
une caravane à chevaux l'autre et nous
ben comme a été dit frère et sœur et
endormi dessous
du Grand péage de chaise parce que je
suis du Grand paillage aussi je fais du
cadenage en
identité
c'est c'est la vie c'est nous c'est
notre vie c'est dehors parce que des
maisons moi des maisons mais moi je suis
en caravane nos bus c'est le feu la
chasse la chasse des hérissons pas HLM
non ça existe pas ça chez nous moi quand
je suis quand je suis en maison pour moi
c'est la prison j'ai fait pas mal de
stars
j'ai fait 20 ans de prison en 86 je suis
j'avais même pas 15 ans j'ai eu une
bagarre
avec ma famille puis une histoire qui
s'est passé je me suis fait moi
personnellement à 15 ans je me suis fait
égorger là je suis passé la cigarette de
la mort et à ce moment-là ben après ben
j'ai racheté couteau j'ai mis 27
couteaux et bien il est à l'hôpital et
puis il est mort après suite de ses
blessures avant que j'étais en prison
pour pour qu'il est mort à l'époque
c'est pas vrai il y a 35 36 ans à
l'époque j'ai fait pas beaucoup de
prison et à l'époque tu payais donc ils
avaient ramassé comment j'étais mineur
mon père il avait pris pour moi donc
c'est mon père qui avait pris mon père
avait pris il avait pris ils l'ont mis
en prison aussi et après ils m'ont
relâché à moi et mon père il a payé à
l'époque en France 20 millions 20
millions à l'époque ça représente 30000
€ à l'époque il a payé mon père est-ce
que j'ai fait j'ai fait maintenant et je
pense ça sera refaire je réfléchiré des
autres membres j'ai pas fait la violence
pour rien juste pour le plaisir et quand
tu as une histoire malheureusement tu la
cherche pas parce que c'est déjà
c'est déjà la misère quand tu te bats la
misère quand elle est l'histoire et puis
quand tu fais des années de prison pour
rien du tout comme ça et parce que
l'autre il a plus fort que toi tu es une
grande gueule et nous bon à l'époque
j'étais jeune je voulais toujours voulu
savoir qui j'étais Jo Lopez et je suis
jamais rabaissé j'ai jamais baissé les
yeux et j'ai toujours été légèrement
j'ai jamais reculé comme de la musique
qui dit avant c'est au revoir à l'époque
j'étais jeune et j'aimais ça en vrai
j'ai mes messages et puis voilà j'ai
fait des millions de combat
avec des gens mais honnêtement c'est pas
pour ça que je suis plus fort que tout
le monde n'est plus méchant mais je
reste toujours du Lopez j'aime pas en
profite sur les gens faible ça serait
n'importe qui voilà je me suis battu
même pour dégager pour des gadgets pour
des Français j'ai pris l'avion parti
pour des voyageurs pour moi ma famille
après je fais je me battais voilà
j'allais dans les grandes mais comme
on se battait je donnais de l'argent et
on se battait toi c'était je payais pour
me battre pour ceux qui comme un combat
mais loyal n'est pas de tu vois c'était
après on va finir sur la main c'est fini
donc les gens ils ont voulu essayer pour
pour
toi j'étais je suis aussi moi je me sens
comme ça et maintenant ça va parce que
avant je me sentais pas bien parce que
les gens ils visaient ils me juger tu
vois ils arrivent quand j'arrive sur
quand j'arrive quelque part et j'étais
je me sentais visé par des gens de
droite du doigt comme ça il y a toujours
là et donc je sais que c'était pas
alors aujourd'hui comme j'ai dit je suis
malade je savais un cancer en prison
c'est pas pour c'est bon on peut pas
dire c'est bon personne on va dire je
vais pas dire que c'est pas pour moi
mais c'est pour personne j'ai pu on
dirait plus de peu envie d'aller en
prison parce que si jamais en prison je
vais je vais écrire la dernière fois
j'étais en prison il fallait j'avais des
Chinois offerts j'avais des chimio
j'avais des examens à faire ils
montent-on le numéro ben crève en prison
moi j'ai connu des gens qui ont en
prison ils étaient mal ils ont crevé en
prison plein plein tu demandes je suis
malade ils m'ont emmener un doliprane
c'est un cancer ça doliprane tu as mal
aux têtes tu as mal au bras tu as mal au
cul c'est de les prendre il y a pas de
bah moi j'étais connu mais voilà il y a
une vidéo qui a fait le buzz sur
Internet qui a fait le buzz qui a fait
le même tour du monde parce que
maintenant que ça soit de mon ordin en
parle je suis du Lopez voilà
regardez-moi si je m'appelle Jules Lopez
là je suis Clermont-Ferrand et à cause
d'une vidéo là malheureusement ben je
suis ici aujourd'hui mais voilà c'est
comme ça ça fait le buzz je vais te dire
franchement je te le dis ça serait
refaire je leur ai jamais fait cette
vidéo
j'en ai trouvé après les gens que je
connais pas que j'avais pas trouvé mais
il y en a que j'ai vu le jour que je
l'ai choperais je ferai du mal ça il
même si je suis handicapé je ferai du
mal c'est pas moi j'étais en prison
c'est pour mon sang je me suis combattu
mais en fin de compte après avoir que la
famille c'est plus la famille c'était
avant ma famille maintenant c'est
aujourd'hui actuellement c'est voilà
chacun sa beauté quand on se voit sans
se voir mais c'est sans plus c'est plus
la famille qui avait avant avant tu es
solidaire
soyez des cousins que ce soit il la
famille elle était là que maintenant
c'est les gens ils ont pensé trop à
l'argent ils pensent trop l'argent donc
ils pensent qu'à leur gueule il y a plus
de famille je veux discuter un exemple
quand j'ai fait une fusillade quand j'ai
pris une balle là que j'étais condamné
j'étais en cavale j'étais en Caval je me
suis mis dans un truc de voyageurs il y
avait 200 caravanes je suis arrivé le je
suis parti faire ma tournée du travail
quand ils ont su que c'était moi qui
était là aujourd'hui et quand j'ai
quelque part c'est pareil quand j'arrive
dans un air de gens du voyage quand
j'arrive là non j'y vois et ça couche là
aujourd'hui pareil et moi ça ça m'énerve
et les voyageurs qui sont bien puis il y
en a qui comme des fois je suis avec des
voyageurs ils sont contents ils arrivent
pas ça fait des photos des photos tout
le monde les gamins tout tu vois ils
sont contents
ça me fait plaisir des fois c'est pas
pareil je suis un homme comme tout le
monde malheureusement les gens me jugent
je pense que je ne suis pas alors c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs j'ai fait ce petit
livre là comme ça ils pourront ben le
lire si c'est mamie leur intéresse au
lieu de me critiquer comme ça pendant si
bien il y a toujours des bons et des
mauvais alors je t'expliquer ce livre là
je l'ai fait pour une raison je l'ai pas
fait pour gagner de l'argent parce que
je dirais pas l'argent que ça et je l'ai
fait parce que bon je t'ai dit je suis
j'ai des problèmes santé je suis malade
j'étais malade j'ai eu un cancer donc
j'étais soigné donc c'est bien ça peut
revenir tout moment donc aujourd'hui et
j'ai des petits enfants que qui me
connaissent mais ils savent pas qui je
suis et donc j'ai fait ce livre là le
jour je sais plus là ils auront au moins
quelque chose pour dire un héritage de
leur grand-père chez nous les voyageurs
c'est comme ça quand il y a quelqu'un
qui qui est connu sur le baston ça parle
des gens ça parle
un exemple que je te dis mettons il y a
quelqu'un qui arrive là hop qui arrive
qui fait le bordel tu vois et qui
cherche la merde il y en a qui laisse
passer ben si mon frère ou mes enfants
il dirait bien au moins cousin si jamais
le jour là ben ça sera pas passé comme
ça ça veut dire donc c'est c'est
héritage là que je laisse allez je vous
Lopez en force les gars du 63